كيف يمكن معرفه انتماء الرجل التركي من
شاربه لنكتشف ذلك معا
[موسيقى]
من الاشياء الملفته التي اكتشفتها هنا انه
يمكنك معرفه توجه التركي من شاربها كان
يكون قوميا او يساريا او حتى اسلاميا
فالشارب في تركيا لديه دلالات ابعد من
التزيين وقد ياخذ احيانا مخزن سياسيا يريد
صاحبه ان يعبر عنه ويبرزه لكن الاجنبي لا
يدرك ذلك بسهوله وقد منع الطلاب والموظفون
سابقا من ابرازه كي لا تعرف انتماءاتهم
لنبدا مع المتدينين والمحافظين فهم
يتميزون بشارب خفيف ومن اشهر الامثله على
ذلك الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان وسلفه الرئيس
عبد الله قول
اما القوميون فيفضلون شارب الطويل والمتجه
للاسفل مثل حدوه الحصان ويقول بعضهم انه
يرمز للهلال الموجود على العالم التركي
بينما يميل اليساريون الى تنميه شوارب
كثيفه على غرار الزعيم السوفيتي جوزيف
ستالين ومع سقوط الاتحاد السوفيتي بدا
يغيب هذا الشكل تدريجيا
لكن هذه الايام ظاهره التمييز الشارب
تتقلص بين الشباب الاتراك ويتجه العديد
منهم الى اطلاق لحام العصريه التي تتقاطع
مع جميع الايديولوجيات
[موسيقى]